in der Schweiz gibt es wirklich
Geisteskranke Zugstrecken
[Musik]
ich habe letztens den Gläschen Express
ein Luxuszug der von St moritz nach
Zermatt fährt ausprobiert und das war
echt krass nachdem ich morgens in St
Moritz aufgewacht bin und es ungefähr so
aussah habe ich mich auf den Weg zum
Bahnhof gemacht um dort in den glasses
fest zu steigen ich hatte erste Klasse
gebucht mit Essen und so weiter 5
Stunden waren wir unterwegs für
umgerechnet ca 255 € man fährt halt
komplett durch die Schweizer Alpen und
ich muss sagen diese Landschaften waren
einfach so real und das ganze in einem
Panoramazug zu werden hat es natürlich
noch mal krasser gemacht so leute wir
machen hier gerade einen kleinen
Zwischenstopp ja also das ist auf jeden
Fall die ich nie vergessen werde das
Essen an Bord war wirklich eine zehn von
zehn und ich habe jede Minute genossen
würdest jederzeit wieder machen und kann
es euch echt empfehlen checkt mal den
Classic Express aus und folgt mir für
weitere zugvideos